Jin Xiu Apple first of all the packaging
is so much nicer than our packaging this
is some classy ask a cat's it looks like
a KitKat it does not smell like a KitKat
hmm that is so strange it's really good
it actually tastes like apples quite a
Polly indeed as soon as it hits your
tongue you can just chase the Apple and
then it goes away and let you enjoy the
chocolate yeah that's a kick out with
apple flavor pumpkin mmm plum like
material coming out of a green pumpkin
head you have this mischievous little
boy with a giant spoon chasing a pumpkin
terrified for his [ __ ] life look how
scared the pumpkin is he's like the
pumpkin is gonna smack you in the face
it's not like the pumpkin latte and do
all those things like it does not taste
good but I do kind of enjoy its like
pumpkin spice without the spice it's
just pumpkin this is tea flavored
without long it's like a classy sort of
grown-up KitKat duck poo coloured is the
colour of goose poop
hell yes if you like teeth then you're
gonna like this
everyone's combinated how this tastes
like weed right what is this cheesecake
cheesecake I love cheesecake who doesn't
like a good cheesecake there are ships
wheels all over the packaging well I
would have seen it's because it's the
Oklahoma Edition and you promised a port
town the cheese is a lot it's a little
bit more cheese than cake at first but
it's like going into the back kitchen of
a Cheesecake Factory and discovering a
terrible secret red bean paste bar you
put a red bean paste and a kick-out why
is it in between two slices of bread
that's red bean sandwich flavor I'll
tell you I like sandwiches I like beans
like kid cats I never thought I would
have them all on the same place no no oh
it tastes like sour beans
it tastes like beans and chocolates this
smells like the chocolate version of
going to a thrift shop and then
immediately walking out okay not like
this very much
the answer is this probably tastes like
what red bean tastes like I don't know
being a man break break me off a piece
of that to that bar